Now that we have looked at learning curves,
let's look at another performance metric, the accuracy.
In case of a classifier,
the accuracy is the fraction of predictions that are correct.
By correct, we mean the negative instances are classified as negative,
and the positive instances are classified as positive.
The loss function, in this case, is a 0, 1 loss.
The risk is given by the misclassification error.
Another way to look at this,
is simply to count the number of times our model correctly classified our data.
So, the accuracy of a classifier can be given as the sum of the true
positives and the true negatives, divided by the total number of occurrences.